remember how heated the debates were
with college athletes getting paid
well things are changing this is a
forbes story when blake lawrence
co-founded athlete marketing the
platform open doors in 2012 the idea
college athletes turning the profit on
sponsorships
and endorsements was a pipe dream
outlawed by the double the
ncaa but lawrence could see the
opportunity and now with laws allowing
college athletes to profit from their
name
images and likeness nil for the first
time set to take the
take effect in seven states on july 1st
his fate is about to be rewarded
this is going to be a no sleep july
lawrence tells forbes
open doors projects the nil market will
be worth
500 million dollars in 2022 its first
full year
before maturing to roughly a billion
annually
every founder dreams of a regulatory
change that creates
billion dollar market in their space
overnight lauren says 32 years old so
by the way props to lawrence in 2012
you come up with this waiting nine years
for this to become a reality from 2012
talk about a visionary by the way
good things uh colin they came out with
this rule or is this a bad thing
them getting paid college athletes bad
thing for the ncaa great thing for
athletes great thing for commerce
uh do ticket prices go up do what what
goes
what how are things effective depending
on the sport
volleyball players aren't making that
loot well that's the thing lacrosse
players it's all gonna be football and
basketball well yeah but
maybe maybe not because you're gonna
look at some
you know like dave portnoys that are
gonna hire these
you know hot model and girls that are
volleyball players
okay i mean they could easily make a ton
of money wearing certain
you know bras and fitness attire and
stuff like that
because they're showing a lot of skin
right so sex sells as well the big thing
is title nine
how does this affect title ix right you
talk about
well it's equal it's more than equal
opportunity it's equal financing
it's equal payment for you down here in
miami a-rod
i believe it was about 10 years back
a-rod wanted to give two-and-a-half
million dollars to the university of
miami baseball team and they said well
thank you a-rod we have to give one and
a half million to uh the baseball team
and one-and-a-half to the softball
teammates
i didn't play softball you're like oh
it's title matt and he can't and he's
like okay you don't get the money
so such [ __ ] yeah it's so that he
should be able to put the money where he
wants to put it right that's the idea
right so so
they title ix started you know like
everything else and this
literally goes back full circle to the
meet kevin you know the people like to
to dismiss it as a slippery slope
fallacy fallacy it's not man
it is not this is thinking your next
five steps this is sitting there saying
okay what's happening next there are
actual
you know policy decisions that have
negative effects and when you see the
negative effects they have to attract
them but they don't because there's too
much pride involved especially when it
comes to academia especially when it
comes
to the far leftist academia where we
know everything about everything
so they get rid of sports instead of
adding to them cheerleading costs too
much money the most expensive sport
in america is cheerleading the insurance
is through the roof these girls get hurt
all the time
they get cancer neck when they go up to
catastrophic injuries
so they get rid of cheerleading and then
because they get rid of cheerleading
because it's so expensive well then they
have to get rid of
equal amounts i can see you totally
being that dude on the cheerleading team
like just
throwing girls up there in the outer
space basically lifting them up with one
hand i actually can't see you being the
one throwing
i feel like with gerard and mr olympia
seven times mister let me have phil even
hold him
throw my ass up there that's fine does
it make does it make the athletes better
what this than being able to get paid
because sometimes you know like you need
adversity to actually improve right
where's the motivation for them
look when i played ball in college i
wasn't a star at
all but i can only imagine um
seeing some of these athletes at other
schools driving into mercedes
you know i'm over here driving into beat
up acura you know
and that person is starting to play
really well
but then next thing you know they're
like what's the motivation for me to go
to class what's the motivation for me to
you know perform like
you're now going to have more
opportunity than the coach
so now you're going to be told what if
you're a star on the team oh
100 like this what's a trickle-down
effect why are they going to college
anyway guys
like why like like well that's just well
it's gonna
know how to answer that okay i'll give
you a perfect example with football
right football you have to wait until
your third year or your 21st birthday to
be draft eligible
right why why yeah you can tell jason
pierre paul was going to be an nfl
player when he was 17 years old why
isn't he going into a minority
in the nba it's just one year though
it's just one year but even the fact
it's one year in the nba right now
you don't think that's a good idea no
not at all so dude if you're
because they have back room deals with
the ncaa so guess what
all of that okay look here's what i
wrote here
a bad idea always gets exposed it's just
period people are eventually going to
expose a bad idea it's a terrible idea
they're going to expose it here's what i
mean by it
it's just a matter of time right to
address a couple things that you got you
said
uh here's the first thing uh you said uh
they have to pay the price when you were
going you didn't have any money you were
playing the
basketball for uh colorado university
college university of denver
university of denver and you're you're
going out there you're you're
majoring in engineer and you're coming
up you're doing things and then also
later on you become a bodybuilder
you don't have any money like dude i'm
trying to barely eat and i can't get
paid all this other stuff
well here's the thing does this really
change anything
meaning were players really not getting
paid i mean of course they were getting
paid but they were getting paid
illegally now you're getting paid
legally meaning marijuana is going to be
has been sold for a long time but people
sold it
illegally now they're selling it legally
alcohol whether you like it or not
we always had alcohol in our house in
iran it wasn't legal we always had it if
you came to our house my dad had plenty
of alcohol if you wanted it
but it was never legal second point here
with
players buying him comes and comes into
the height goes from high school to the
nba right he i don't know if he was a
first or not you had kevin garnett colby
all these guys started coming up who was
the first by the way was kobe the first
was the first series jonathan garnett
no no tyson chandler i don't know was it
moses malone i think moses
okay so so then check this out so so the
maturity level goes
the 17 18 year old coming in and they
get all this money
into the in the nba right the biggest
concern for me is
a lot of money a lot of success early
and your mindset still doesn't
understand how money works which means
you're going to be abused
you're going to be taking advantage of
them people are going to be taking money
away from you so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye